WE SAW HIM IN CENTER.CO.
THE PERCENTAGES GO RIGHT
OUT OFOF
ON , STOPPED IN HIS
TRACKS. BY MARK IS OVER. CLEAR
WAY TO THE NET BY GUSTAFSSON
HIM.ON-TWO.
AND IT TURNED INTO A . HE HAS B
FANTASTIC TONIGHT .
>>
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
>> Ray: THE LEAFS SHOWED A LOT
IN THIS THIRD PERIOD.
THEY COME THIS CLOSE TO THEEURY
POWER-PLAY.
THE TALK IS JUST GOING WALKS IT
MIDDLE.
>> Garry: WHAT A GREAT
OVERTIME.N.
TO THE BACKDOOR!
AND THEN THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL
SAVE FROM MARC-ANDRE FLEURY.
ANDREW MANGIAPAP
IN PLAY.
I THINK THERE WAS A FEELING
FRONT AND, OH, WHAT A STOP!
DID YOU SEE THAT?!UP
FOR THIS YEAR.
MARTINEZ FADES INTO THE GLASS.
PUTS ON THE BRAKES.S. ROBBED
NAZ
A 3-0 LEAD.
A LOT OF THAT DUE  I CAN'T MRS.
NET, OUTFRONT, PUCK LOOSE, IT ,
SAVE THE PERIOD.
SPURGEON, CROSSING SOONER.
FEEDS IT ACROSS .
SPURGEON, A GREAT  THE GOAL PAS!
>> John: WHAT A IT IN. A SAVE!
MARC-ANDRE FLEURY
TO TAKE THIS FACE-OFF.
SMITH PLAYS
YOU RARELY SEE THIS ANYMORE. AN.
>> Shane: OPENING IT UP.
ODD-MAN FOR THE
SHARKS.
AND PULL AWAY FROM MCNABB WHO
PUSHAGAINST SAN
JOSE.
LOSES THE PUCK, HAS TO
OVER THE GOAL AND PUTTING PUCKS
ON GOAL.BY FLEURY.
A  COME WITH SOME
SPEED.
AS THEY MOVE IT THE
GOOD DEFENSIVE TICK BY N THE
OTHER SIDE.
OVER, AND BACK OUT TOOU'VE CALL
LIKE THIS IF THEY CAN CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES DOWN LOW AND NOT
>> Kenny: KOLESAR AND
SO IF YOU GET ANOTHER LINE
CHANGE FOR COLORADO, YOU HAVE TO
>> Kenny: GAME SIX,
SUZUKI THERE.
CLEARED BY FLEURY.
ANOTHER CHANCEACROSS.
MAKES THE GLOVE SAVE.
NOW TRYING TO FIND IT O
OUTSTANDING GOALTENDING IN HIS ,
WINNIPEG, MINNESOTA, BOY, IT'S
TOUGH.
>>
FABBRI, OH, FABBRI CAN'T BELIEVE
IT.
>>
REESE JOHNSON.
WHO'S CUT OFF AT THE PASS BY
HIS BA B
TURNING POINT IN A
GAME.
LOOK AT THIS
BEAUTIFUL LITTLE
DROPS IT DEFENSIVE PLAY.
HE CLEARS IT THEIKE THAT MacKIN
ONE-TIME SHOT.
CONTENDING WITH NATHAN
MacKINNON.
SAVE. UNBELIEVABLE SAVE BY. HER
McCANN, GIORDANO FROM THE LINE.
TOP OF THE  DAY DOWN RIGHT HEREP
AND DOWN, DISJOINTED A LITTLE
BIT.
THERE'S A QUICK CENTERING PASS.
COMING.
HE WAS ABLE TO BLOCK THAT JACK
JOHNSON SHOT.
OH, MYSAVE. ITH THE GLOVE